I am a reformed Jew and I have never
celebrated Christmas ever
Christmas was not something I ever
learned how to celebrate as a young
child Jesus was born December of 25th
and then time started all the little
kids in the family wake up really really
early everyone's wearing matching
pajamas all of the children and these
are adult children's line up in order of
size and then the parents watches the
children run down the stairs and then
everyone goes Christmas I mean it's just
kind of scary like all of a sudden
there's all these like bells and
chestnuts
there's just bells everywhere and then
they open all the presents it's way too
many presents at some point during the
year you have to give you kid a $200
electronic Christmas has been set up to
be that thing and they have the stocking
but if you get coal in your stocking
then you're not a bad person but your
parents are sociopaths and then the tree
dies and Christ is born I don't know why
you do that I guess to distract yourself
because you're like if you go home
you're just gonna be like there's
presents oh I guess we'll go to church
to distract ourselves six-year-old girl
playing the Virgin Mary they like dress
up as donkeys and angels your children
love to dress up like peppermint sticks
and like little Christmas trees I think
that people listen to Himes people like
wearing jeans to church I've heard and
maybe also just like a lot of Mariah
Carey Christmas covers Christmas dinners
ham right I have like ham ham again I
think there's a lot of hand happen they
eat the opposite of like what Jews meet
something like ham you got pineapple
slices maybe get a brisket so there's
like a toothpick in each pineapple slice
with a cherry on top yeah now there's
gingerbread cookie and you are like
Christmas hats right you are like a
Santa hat and Chris was bitter can you
eat mistletoe
in a feat of acrobatics a fat man with a
beard and a giant like satchel of
presents comes down a tiny little hole
downtown the course of one night
delivers presents to the whole world he
doesn't come to my house which is weird
like how does he know to see see like
them as those on the door he's like a
Santa travels in a little like the wagon
with the here are the seven reindeer
Rudolph on Jupiter on snowball Neptune
they're not they're not the Sailor
Scouts I don't know her name
one of them's Bosh right real mean
through Duff you is there Prancer you're
like f you need to name the backup
dancers on Beyonce's tour I can't do it